DMI stands for business model innovation
innovation is often thought to be doing
something new but mostly doing something
new by developing a new technology
finding a new market or designing a
product or battle match consumer needs
business model innovation is a different
kind of innovation this is where you
produce basically the same product
address the same market needs but the
way in which you provision this product
to the market involves a new business
model this could be a new revenue model
this could be a new cost model or most
interestingly it could be in different
risk model all of these models might
help you disrupt incumbents change the
way things are done in industry in an
industry and provide a superior product
superior services and and disrupt the
game in the in the industry so first off
I think BMI as an approach is not not
only about mitigating risk it is more
about managing risk so we often think
risk is a bad thing we got a risk is
going to hurt our business risk is
always a bad thing
turns out companies that can better
manage risk companies that can
differentiate themselves from the
incumbents in how their business model
deals with the risk might have a
significant advantage over the
incumbents over the folks who don't do
that so we can think of in the in the
transportation industry a company like
like uber which is this transportation
network provider company the
taxi-hailing
app sama-sama some of you might know
compare that to a traditional taxi
service provider or a black car service
provider now a black car service
provider has has a much more risk in its
business model because it has to invest
in in in a heavy asset load before any
any demand shows up company like uber on
the other hand has a business model
which has a lot lot lower risks because
it's the costs and revenue scale up
together if a lot of people want born
taxi rides you were ends up bringing in
a lot of drivers on board if nobody
wants a taxi ride there are no drivers
who are paid and that that business
model manages the demand risk in a lot
superior fashion than a traditional taxi
model does
and that allows it to differentiate
itself from the traditional model and
and provide a superior service to
consumers basically a service which
allows them to almost guarantee a car
within a few minutes irrespective of
where where they are or irrespective of
the time of the day that's that's using
risk to differentiate yourself not only
as as something you have to worry about
or try to mitigate